le canada a retiré stéphane guillon à la
tête de sa diplomatie
trop diplomate pas assez bilingue selon
dédire pour mieux faire face selon des
analyses à ces deux hommes trompent et
poutine et pour désarmer l'opposition
quoi de mieux que cette femme
semble-t-il christina ou christian
fouine bientôt 49 ans mois tricia phelan
je promets et jour solonnellement est
sincèrement qu'au mieux de ma compétence
et de ma connaissance j'exécuterai
loyalement et fidèlement les pouvoirs et
je me tairai des responsabilités qui
m'ont été confiées qualité du ministère
est une ancienne journaliste dans une
variété de positions éditoriales au
financial times du globe and mail de
toronto et chic thomson re uters où elle
était le directeur général et rédacteur
en chef des articles sur la consommation
connaissant l'opinion donald trump sur
les journalistes
cela définit un terrain de jeu
géopolitique au départ intéressant c'est
un ajustement et binet qui effectivement
motivée par l'arrivée donald trump on
cherche une manière atawad d'arrimer le
les différents ministères pile
l'orientation politique avec celle des
années castonguay journaliste et chef de
bureau politique au magazine québécois
l'actualité le grand perdant semble être
stéphane guillon et ilia ii l'une
rencontre avec du spectre dos en fin de
semaine il est sorti très mécontents de
la rencontre on sait pas exactement où
va atterrir ses fans bien qu'on va lui
donner un autre ministère qu'on lui
offre quelque chose d'autre mais c'est
certainement une d'émotion parce qu'ils
étaient très mécontents de cette
rencontre le donc ces femmes dit on
regarde le ministère des affaires
étrangères pour des raisons double je
dirais d'affinités d'abord parce que y'a
pas beaucoup d'affinités en stéphane
dion et la nouvelle administration
donald trump longtemps sur le ton
stéphane guillon est un intellectuel
assez carassins assez loin de ton
populiste l'administration de donald
trump il est aussi le champion de la
lutte aux changements climatiques
souvenez vous du grand virage bas qu'il
voulait imposer lorsqu'il était chef du
parti libéral en 2007 on veut avoir dans
ce poste là avec l'administration
tremblay white
très imprévisible quelqu'un qui est prêt
du premier ministre une communication
parfaite que la confiance de justin
trudeau donc dans une guerre commerciale
qui se prépare avec les etats-unis
peut-être négociations de l'alena mais
en temps sur le mode le bois noble qui
va prendre effet ce printemps aussi donc
il connaît déjà ce très très bien ce
domaine là et en plus est lors du ton
des entrées à washington et à new york
et le travail et aux états unis pendant
plusieurs années elle est donc une
personnalité qui peut être plus moi dans
les cordes de la minustah de
l'administration tout en banque c'est se
retrouve à ce poste là ce serait pas
très étonnant et l'as partant des choses
elle devra ajuster le dans son dans son
discours est peut-être expliquer
certaines choses à l'administration
trois ans par exemple et les pas très
partisan de rapprochement avec la russie
on sait que la mission l'administration
toi même beaucoup la russie donc ça il
va peut être y avoir un petit quelque
peu de frictions et leurs écrits ont
livré quelques années sur le fameux 1%
le qui s'enrichit au départ j'ai 99 pour
ça avec un tracé bleu cas évocateurs le
plus tôt crap de rise of the new global
reach je sais qu'il ya beaucoup de
millionnaires et de milliardaires au
cabinet de dans l'album donc je les
phillies son livre peut-être qu'ils vont
se sentir un peu visible assez
étonnamment elle est peut-être
provenance bien connu par aussi dans les
milieux médiatiques car si vous souvenez
que à cnn et l'étape et elle est apparue
très souvent en compagnie de fareed
zakaria pour discuter des grandes
questions économiques du monde donc si
vous voulez si quelqu'un qui a déjà une
réputation et qui en plus de sa
remarquable entre gens qui s'expriment
très bien qui connaît les dossiers
économiques
le professeur et ancien diplomate
canadien ferry de kerchove
aujourd'hui politicologue à université
d'ottawa
je crois que monsieur trudeau est arrivé
pouvoir en disant qu'il allait d'abord
mettre à l'ordre du jour le
rétablissement si vous voulez des
relations entre le canada et les états
unis on connaît la sphère qui stone et
les difficultés que monsieur affaire
avait eu avec monsieur obama et je crois
que ce changement surtout évidemment à
la veille de l'entrée en piste de donald
trump montrent clairement que monsieur
trudeau a fait un choix fondamental les
relations canado américaines sont les
plus importants de tous telles que l'on
a d'une part une large
mesure et que l'arrivée de monsieur
thiam change la donne et qu'il a décidé
et c'est une façon assez sain de
l'expliquer qu'il a choisi quelqu'un
qu'il estime être meilleur pour faire
face à la tourmente
ou en tout cas certainement à un
engagement dans des relations qui seront
quand même extrêmement compliqué va
falloir répondre aux droits et rêve de
bien défendre nos dossiers opinion de
guy lachapelle professeur au département
de science politique de l'université
concordia à montréal il est secrétaire
général de l'association internationale
de science politique surtout créer des
liens de nouveau lié évidemment monsieur
tout doit vers une relation j'aurais
privilégié avec monsieur obama avec
l'administration démocrate
on a des républicains maintenant pouvoir
y il est aussi son malheur qu'on pense
au bois de l'industrie automobile
question de l'énergie dans l'ouest
la question du bois de vaux québec et
dans les provinces maritimes
ce sont de gros enjeux et qui vont
demander déjà avec de grosses pointures
pour négocié ses hôtes a des qualités de
me suis dit oh ça prend quelqu'un qui
ont une compétence dans le domaine de la
politique dans les négociations
commerciales et internationale quelque
chose d'important et l'autre l'autre
élément g recchi qui était c'est
fondamental
cependant les gouvernent libéral de
monsieur trudeau c'est d'avoir aussi des
gens qui sont de bons communicateurs
monsieur dion et le grandes qualités
intellectuelles mais bien sur le plan de
la communication tout le monde le sait
très bien souvent ça passe pas lorsqu'il
s'agit des clips utiles aux citoyens
il y est même aux politiques et les
avantages par exemple du libre échange
que trop de protectionniste nuit au tant
aux états unis qu'au canada au mexique
c'est le je pense que cet aspect de leur
apprendre à jouer beaucoup d'indigènes
vers qu'ils ont mis leno sur le tableau
christie a free il n'avait été nommée ce
mois-ci l'une des cinquante plus
influentes personnalités toronto par un
magazine toronto life
un reportage de radio canada
international